this is the season finale of season one
grappling-hook I told you it'd come in
handy yes yes right I think from episode
1 they've been pushing the Grand Fling
hook and you have just gone completely
mental but I don't blame you naca to me
I don't blame you because this is like
the most incredible cliffhanger for me
uncle Stan's got all three books
he's got three books you can see the
symbol that the that bill cipher was
seen before and that's also on the flag
it's on the side I never know is that
before the so that symbol keeps popping
up um which is I which is my cuz all the
earth stuff I like I wrote down it's
just my stuff like hey look they had the
Disney font for gideonland and uh then I
never knew what the eyepiece was in the
book um that you can read it easier but
but why just maybe like the person day
has only one eye or maybe it's even Bill
ciphers eye I don't know aids insurance
it's just one eyepiece um and the only
other thing I noticed is that the the
gnome cologne is just n om a little
mountain on top of the oh oh I thought
that was very funny oh I just all three
bucks okay you say ought to be good
before like literally like grunkle Stan
pulled out book number one and that was
literally my reaction Doug laughs cuz I
just went know that that was pretty much
my reaction when I first saw this one I
mean everything is this is a great
episode I mean this is just always epic
it had a creepy ass gideon
little yes and remember to wear your
buttons it's my face it way it was funny
it was really big it was really epic it
had some great action in it i'll really
creative the giant robotic gideon kills
me again it's both just really kind of
threatening and really funny
maple provides moral support and though
she just she does end up in Gideon's
grass but even at the end though she
saves the day quite a point on well
that's what I like about they both kind
of end up saving each other cows
everybody kind of saves everybody in the
show what is nice mentioned that he was
a part-time bus driver when he was in
the restaurant and it showed dipper in
the bus dipper and Mabel in the bus with
the gum that looked like the face
Abraham Lincoln no Reagan thank you oh
I'm sorry Reagan yeah the face of Ronald
Reagan um and the Canadian coin when
they were being chased by the giant
robot I'm like and he goes bus driver
I'm like please be Zeus pls b0ss pls
Zeus and then it was and I was like
um so this episode Gideon takes over the
mystery shack they had to live with
Seuss's uh grandma and they're trying to
find a way to get it back at first it
looks like they had to be sent home
which is one of the scenes where it's
like you know they're not gay get sent
home you know they're not but it's
legitimately kind of were sad yeah that
was legitimately sad and the other thing
that was sad was when he was abusing
waddles and I was like he's like he
blows the whistle on the pigs like her
and he's like get back that corner and I
was like oh oh no oh no nobody does that
to waddles um and yes I thought you know
it's one of the few times you see Stan
like legitimately sad not kind of like
ironic or just a hint it's like he is
actually really really sad to see the
kids go uh and it works it doesn't feel
for us it feels very you know you know
it's let's see we've seen a lot of kid
shows where it's like they're going oh
no they're gonna be gone even though you
know and I'm like I love it when Stan's
initially lying he's like don't worry
your son and daughter fine ya know if I
really felt I couldn't take care of him
I would send them home so like I felt
that even though he's a liar and you
could read it as always just lying to
cover him so I really felt like he
wanted to be able to take care of them
and felt really bad that he couldn't
yeah why eventually he decides to send
them home but it first is like I can do
this well which makes me even sadder
when he does send them all cuz you know
he really doesn't want to you know he
really wants in this day that's sweet uh
yeah and the the action scene with the
giant robotic Gideon I think is great I
love the Frog suit he wears he's able to
steer it so yeah Japanese mecca's well
it's got the dots out to the motion
camera and stuff come on when dipper
breaks through the eye and starts
fighting him in the robots like oh yeah
I mean that guy it's I don't know like
this episode like I already love this
show for this episode in particular I'm
watching just like this is kind of
everything I want in a really funny
entertaining cartoon show you know it's
like I like to have a target avatar yeah
avatar is a serious show with a lot of
funny elements this is a comedy with a
lot of serious elements in Hannah and
was really epic on top of that yeah and
it had the mystery like that's the one
thing like a lot of the episodes we saw
in this sort of round that we've done
didn't have the mystery the exception of
the one before with the SI with the bill
cipher and like yeah after a while I was
kind of like well they're very fun and
entertaining but I kind of missed the
mystery and now we got it back in a big
way yeah that uh that ending like I said
cuz I was saying before that's like
alright I'm not gonna watch any more
episodes Rob just gonna finish off the
season I'll wait for season two and then
I saw that ending I'm like no no I can't
stop there it's impossible for anyone to
stop there I put into season two
Oh plus the gnomes are back yes the
gnomes game bag they're still hilarious
of the squirrel bath whoo no I love the
fact that's most likely not a gnome
thing that's just particular gnome thing
what that's a good ZZZ Jenna uh yeah
this is what gnomes do I swear this is
what we do pat pat dug schmira that all
you can say shrim you rock oh yeah i
what i love is that there's like a pause
like he's trying to think of something
else to say but he notes he kiss me ramp
you look but the tiny other day I was so
gnomes came back I hell else was I gonna
say I forget they as usual though the
gnomes hover in that weird world of like
funny and occasionally legitimately
creepy when they all gang up on you I'm
just like yeah they're kind of creepy
like when they're hauling them off like
I like when they use other nose as like
arrows yeah uh I love this well that's
what I was gonna say when the gnomes
have got dipper and Mabel and Gideon's
out saying that take him away and the
journal falls out he's like yeah you had
it all along and I'm just like oh no oh
no this is bad oh no those two journals
can't this is gatekeeper keymaster
this game like no no no don't open it oh
god but that's me even there by the fact
that you realize it's not the why it's
not the one yeah can for now which makes
it you know it's great that then he's
chasing after them cuz they're still
mister where's the first one when he
pulls it out at the end and he has all
three bones how you're just like what is
is what's it going to be what to the
mounting to arrest for being the fraud
and for breaking our hearts uh I love it
I I don't think I could ask for like a
better ending to a season one a better
cliffhanger um it was great yeah III I
loved it and honestly as much as I loved
the first season I think the second
season gets even funnier and has even
more like cretin no no you lie it helped
it better
this was so good it does get better I
don't know too much awesome too much
awesome we may have to wait no I know we
will not wait we okay well we will wait
but you will see it in the next video
more awesome on the way I put off I can
handle it all
I'm taking that sweater away from him
yeah